[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the Benghazi story the events in
Libya almost six years ago and in
Washington ever since cost lives
shaped history and influenced the
political fortunes of some very
important people here special report
anchor right there September 11th 2012
11 years after the 9/11 attacks a mob
storms the u.s. compound in Benghazi at
the end of the night four Americans are
dead Sean Smith ambassador Chris Stevens
Tyrone woods and Glen Doherty the United
States condemns in the strongest terms
this outrageous and shocking attack the
Obama administration promised to bring
the killers to justice but during the
election year administration officials
and the President himself refused to say
for days whether the brutal attack was
planned or an act of terrorism instead
at first placing the blame squarely on
an anti-muslim video made by an American
the best information and the best
assessment we have today this is a
response to a hateful and offensive
video it began spontaneously in Benghazi
a direct result of heinous and offensive
video that was widely disseminated this
is something we've seen in the past we
would later learn the comments by then
United Nations Ambassador Susan Rice on
all five Sunday talk shows were met with
shocked by State Department employees
but those comments were backed up by
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton who
maintained it was unclear at the time
what was behind the attack later an
email she wrote to her daughter surfaced
an email written within hours of the
assault that makes no mention of the
video and instead blames a quote al
Qaeda like group
this was the fog of war you know my own
assessment careened from you know the
video had something to do with it the
video had nothing to do with it Fox News
tried to track down the
and who made that video Nakula bacilli
Nakula the last time he was interviewed
in 2016 he was living in a homeless
shelter in California and told Fox News
he doesn't believe in democracy anymore
it was the administration's initial
blaming the video the timeline of events
that led up to the attack and word that
ambassador Stevens himself warned that
the security situation in Benghazi was
deteriorating fast that fueled a host of
investigations the first was the State
Department's own 39 page unclassified
report that stops short of implicating
Secretary of State Clinton for any
wrongdoing but did find a breakdown in
senior leadership and four employees
were taken off the job for several
months before being reassigned we fixed
it at the assistant secretary level
which is in our view the appropriate
place to look the where the
decision-making in fact takes place
where if you like the rubber hits the
road
eight congressional committees would
investigate the breakdown in Benghazi
over four years a protest or is it
because of guys out for a walk one night
I decided they'd go kill some Americans
what difference at this point does it
make House Select Committee on Benghazi
chairman trey Gowdy says his committee
set out to seek answers not to be
involved in the politics of it I wanted
to both debunk this to the extent that
were miss out there about what we were
doing there and what Chris Stevens was
doing there but more than anything else
I wanted to at least be able to tell
Chris Stevens and Shawn Smith and ty
woods and Glen d'Or these loved ones
this is what happened that night the
early morning hours to your loved one
and it is a story of heroism that you
should be
hurly prowls Republicans on the
committee released their findings in
June of 2016
without the endorsement of Democrats
during the heat of Hillary Clinton's
presidential run there's a special place
in hell for people like her and I hope
she enjoys it they're the parents of
victims Sean Smith and ty woods have
been vocal about placing blame on
Hillary Clinton for the failures in
Benghazi and sued the former Secretary
of State alleging negligence and
defamation in March a DC Court
reaffirmed an earlier court's decision
to dismiss those claims I've totally
forgiven everyone that's involved with
the death of my son as for bringing
those directly responsible for the
deaths of four Americans to justice
almost two years after the Benghazi
terror attacks a suspect is now in
custody
Special Forces captured the man believed
to be the ringleader of the attack Ahmed
Abu khattala
in 2014 a man who had been hiding in
plain sight for months it's important
for us to send a message to the world
that when Americans are attacked
no matter how long it takes we will find
those responsible and we will bring them
to justice
Wednesday Hatala was sentenced to 22
years in prison after being found guilty
last November on just four of the 18
counts he faced late last year President
Trump announced the capture of a second
suspect
Mustapha al-imam saying he will face
justice for his role in the attack al
imam has pleaded not guilty today if you
go to the FBI website they're still
asking for information about individuals
who may have been on the grounds on the
mission in Benghazi when it was attacked
Bret Baier Fox News